is honor for me to meet you I'm sorry
Drew Barrymore was seen consoling an
emotional fan during a recent taping of
Global's the Drew Barrymore show in the
heartfelt clip shared to Instagram the
talk show host initially appeared
concerned after noticing the audience
member was in tears
she loves you so much
you're gonna see me coming over I was
like tell me where they are
I will take him down
I don't want to be that person until I
cry oh
yes it turns out they were happy tears
from the audience member named Olivia
and Drew even took the moment to make
herself at home on her lap of course she
did and it's so funny that you would say
like oh I don't want to cry here I cried
here all
and for more Sweet Moments don't miss
the Drew Barrymore show airing weekdays
at 3 P.M Eastern on global